Law School is really expensive and it's
easy to assume that the only good
resources in law school are also really
expensive but that's simply not the case
today we're gonna talk about the free
resources that you should be using to
supercharge your law school education
and get better grades the first free
resource that I would recommend in law
school is called Anki akhi is a digital
flashcard software simply put there is
no better way to help you memorize
things paper flashcards get a bad rap
and part of that is deserved but there's
been a lot of research into the science
of memorizing things over the last 20
years recently study after study has
shown that something called spaced
repetition learning can supercharge your
ability to recall things the basis of
the system is simple the more you
remember something the less you need to
study the less you remember it the more
often you need to see the flashcard unki
has this kind of period is a Schnoor
spaced repetition built into it it's
been used by language learners for years
it allows people to learn entire
languages in just months in fact I'm
using it to learn Japanese right now so
for example if I am displayed a
flashcard and I get the answer right
then I tell the software that I got that
card right and I won't see that a card
again for a day but if I got the card
wrong then I'll see that card again
within one minute I'll keep seeing it
until I get that card right this system
is the fastest way to remember things
like elements of a cause of action or
memorizing the facts of a particular
case if you use visual cues like
pictures or mnemonics you can really
supercharge your ability to learn these
concepts really fast not everything that
you need to learn for final exams is
conductive to being memorized via
flashcards like a key but I'd say that
at least 80% is if you want to memorize
things in the minimum amount of time use
Anki or another spaced repetition
flashcard system it is a great system
very few people use it and it is
perfectly free on a laptop the next free
resource that I would use is West law
West law is
not just the thing that you have to use
in your legal writing a research class
it's also a wonderful tool for short
cutting your study time lawyers are very
lazy they are willing to pay a ton of
money to have things spoon-fed to them
and Westlaw and LexisNexis fill that
need every American case is reported and
analyzed by an army of lawyers here at
legal eagle we recommend commercial
outlines and case summary services like
Quimby but you can get 90% of the
benefit of those things straight from
Westlaw itself they summarize the facts
and most importantly they give you the
black letter law find what works best
for you and your professor between
commercial supplements and outlines but
don't forget the Westhead notes as well
and read those first before you dive
into your case book it will make your
reading so much clearer save you
headaches and save you time we go into
this in more depth in our guide to law
school cases you can get a link to that
down below the third free resource you
should use is your law school librarian
your law school librarians can help you
with just about anything writing
assignments research assignments Law
Review articles just about anything but
the most important thing they can help
you with is practice tests unfortunately
law schools tend to keep a tight lid on
their practice tests so they make it
hard to find and they certainly don't
advertise them your law librarians are
the gatekeepers they are your best
resource for finding prior exams from
your school and most importantly for
your particular professor I talk about
practice exams a lot on this channel
it's one of the most important things
you can do to get better grades so go
get them from your law librarians get as
many as you can get exams from other
professors it doesn't matter just do
them your grades will thank you okay the
next free resource that I would
recommend in law school is Dropbox or
Google Drive some sort of cloud storage
system everyone has a horror story about
their laptop crashing the night before a
writing assignment is due or losing
their outline just before they started
studying all of your law school files
should be pretty small just Word
documents mainly so sign up for a free
Dropbox
Google Drive account automatically save
your work to those folders and while
you're at it tell word to autosave your
work every few seconds your peace of
mind is worth this free resource and
there's just no reason in this day and
age not to have some sort of cloud
system the next free resource I would
recommend is your school's gym it's too
easy to get completely out of shape in
law school thanks to the arms race
between colleges odds are you have
access to a really nice gym on campus
and that probably includes classes that
are free to take at the gym part of
doing well in law school is staying
mentally and physically fit so don't
neglect your gym and don't neglect your
body or your health as well it's too
easy to fall into the trap of eating
nothing but junk food and just studying
all the time but in the long run it is
better for you to stay mentally and
physically fit and that requires that
you go to the gym every once in a while
the next free resource you should
absolutely use in law school is your
professor you should go to office hours
it is amazing how few people actually go
to the professor's office hours these
people are experts in their field and
more importantly they are the ones that
are going to test you on your final exam
so find out what they in particular
think about a certain section of law
their version is more important than any
other resource if your professor
contradicts a commercial supplement go
with your professor that's the version
that's going to be on the test
but you can use your professor to
clarify things that you don't understand
if your professor offers practice exams
do them and then talk about the practice
exam with your professor and talk about
what you can do better find out what you
did wrong and what you did right get to
know the professor your professor is
genuinely interested in the law
otherwise they wouldn't be a professor
and hopefully you are too
if so talk shop go to office hours
getting good grades is only one way to
get a good job remember that getting a
referral from your professor is another
perfectly legitimate way of getting a 1l
or 2l job so get to know the professor
show some genuine interest and use them
to build your network oh and you know
what else will help you get better grade
on your final exam is our guide to law
school which you can download for free
down below you can also check out our
master class where we show you all the
tricks and step-by-step instructions on
how to crush every legal exam and how to
think like a lawyer also subscribe to
our channel we come out with new tips
all the time so from everyone here at
legal eagles see you next time - dee dee
doo dee doo dee dee the first free
resource I would use the first free
resource that I would use is called the
first free resource I would use the
first free resource I would use is
called the first free resource that I
would use in Los the first free resource
oh my god